[Music]
[Narrator:] By air, by land, and by
sea. All routes lead to this southern city.
Beautiful scenery and sunny skies
attract many additional residents each year.
Unfortunately, this climate is also
ideal for one of man's worst enemies:
the aedes aegypti mosquito, carrier of dengue and yellow fever.
[Music]
To combat this menace to the city,
an officer of the United States Public Health Service
cooperated with the local health department.
One of the first steps in the campaign
was to discover permanent mosquito breeding places
such as old cisterns, basins, shallow wells, fire barrels, and numerous other containers capable of holding water.
Health officials have constantly warned
the people of these dangerous conditions,
and of the way mosquitoes spread to smaller receptacles.
After a period devoted to study and
survey, the extent of breeding of the dengue
and yellow fever mosquito was determined.
A special meeting of health officials
set in motion the anti-mosquito campaign.
It was decided that a concerted effort
would be necessary, enlisting the aid of every source of publicity
together with the organized individual
efforts of all the people.
With the health of an entire city
in jeopardy, the mayor promptly issued a proclamation
regarding the urgency of the situation,
and asked that everyone participate in eliminating the dengue-yellow fever mosquito.
Newspapers proved particularly valuable
in awakening the public to an understanding
of their common danger and mutual dependence.
Officials of civic organizations assisted
to help officers in recruiting leaders
and obtaining cooperation from the public through knowledge, rather than action and force by law.
Theaters exhibited short films showing methods of control of the dengue and yellow fever mosquito: Aedes Aegypti.
Teamwork was stimulated in schools
as a direct result of the educational program,
which included the showing of motion pictures on mosquitoes, their life habits,
and various methods of control.
Children are impressed by this method of presentation.
Such knowledge acquired by these citizens
of tomorrow, will be of great influence
in the building of healthy, prosperous communities of tomorrow.
Progress of the campaign was broadcast
daily by local radio stations.
This method was most effective in
reaching the housewife,
the self-appointed guardian of the family welfare,
whose cooperation is vital to the
success of any health campaign.
Instructions and educational material
were supplied to the Boy Scouts,
since they had volunteered to inspect
homes and tell the people about the hazards of the city.
Districts were set up based on geography
and population.
As an additional incentive for action, it was decided to give a V merit award to cooperating residents.
Pamphlets on the aedes aegypti mosquito were made available for distribution to every home,
together with an instruction sheet
showing methods of destroying
their breeding places and posters urging definite action.
Newspaper publicity gave the necessary
day-by-day stimulus for a successful campaign.
Schoolchildren were eager to take
part in the mosquito control program,
since they had been so thoroughly informed of its importance.
Teachers emphasized the necessity
of the campaign by personally distributing
literature for the children to take home.
Parents were interested and realized the need for eliminating the dengue and yellow fever mosquito.
They welcomed instructions on how to get rid of mosquitoes in and around their home.
A call to arms found the Boy Scouts
prepared and anxious to undertake their duty.
After being instructed by their leader, they started on their way to distribute pamphlets and inspect premises.
The Scouts greeted housewives in their usual polite manner
and consequently received cooperation and assistance.
Each scout had received instructions
about possible breeding places
and was determined to make a thorough inspection of each home.
This attitude often stimulated the
housewife's concern and careful observation.
If it holds water, it will hold mosquito
larvae.
Another home, another scout, and another
housewife.
The water in this container is fresh...there are no larvae here but they could develop within a few days.
But let's look in other containers.
Ah, here they are! Who would imagine so many larvae in such a small piece of pottery?
Any container capable of catching
water is a potential mosquito breeding place
and should be immediately destroyed
or emptied and turned bottoms up.
A careful search is necessary to find the hidden containers which provide permanent breeding places.
Larvae become mosquitoes. Mosquitoes
carry disease.
Inside or outside, it makes no difference.
Man-made containers, small and large,
harbor aedes aegypti mosquito larvae.
Discarded containers of this type should always be given to salvage and garbage collectors without delay.
Constant protection of the family
health demands constant vigilance.
All drinking pans should be emptied
and washed at least twice a week.
Mosquitoes breed continually and are
most prolific,
one mosquito being able to lay hundreds
of eggs within a single day.
After each home had been thoroughly
inspected, the cooperative housewife was given a merit award.
Display of this award was evidence
of her intention to continue
keeping her home free from dengue and yellow fever mosquitoes.
Informative articles published in the newspapers were effective in making housewives
conscious of mosquito-breeding places.
The effect of this information was often instantaneous.
Horrified? No wonder. Such a small
plant and all those wiggle tails in the water.
All water plant receptacles in the
home should be emptied and scrubbed twice a week.
The stems of the plant should be carefully
rinsed to remove any remaining mosquito larvae.
A simple operation indeed, but only
by such precautions can any home
be kept free of the disease-carrying aedes aegypti mosquito.
Since most water plants grow well
in soil, it was recommended that where possible
the change be made.
Potted plants never breed mosquitoes.
Girl Scouts were enlisted in the all-out
campaign.
They discovered and destroyed numerous
breeding places including those in cemeteries.
In order to stimulate greater interest
in the collection and destruction of mosquito larvae.
schoolchildren were encouraged to
collect the wiggle tails and feed them to minnows.
Such action also emphasized the importance of fish as a protective measure.
Minnows like these, when placed in
garden pools and similar places, eat mosquito larvae.
Every section of the city was thoroughly inspected.
Vacant lots were found with accumulations
of refuse.
The scouts punched holes in containers
to make sure they would never again be capable
of holding water and mosquito larvae.
Community cooperation is essential
in all health education programs,
since clean-up in one area contributes
to the welfare of the entire community.
Mosquito larvae are often found in
unsuspected places,
such as old discarded tires containing water.
There's just about one efficient way
to get water out of these tires.
And this is it.
After the water is removed from such tires, they should be stored in dry, sheltered locations until salvaged.
This man, by cooperating in the campaign, helps protect the health of his family and neighbors,
thereby receiving the merit award.
Thousands of rusty, damaged containers were promptly removed from homes by the city sanitary department.
This is one of the most effective methods for the permanent elimination of mosquito-breeding places.
A brief survey of the huge collection
was made by health and sanitary officials before salvaging or destruction.
Posters were displayed throughout
the city to keep the public
ever mindful of the mosquito menace.
Store owners contributed window space
for unusual exhibits, conveying to the public
the danger of mosquito breeding.
Various methods of aedes aegypti control
were presented.
The display of live mosquitoes and
larvae attracted the attention of thousands of people.
The larvae-eating minnows impress
many spectators as being an effective way
to combat the mosquito hazard.
The aroused public attitude assured the success of the anti-mosquito campaign.
[Music]
You have just observed how one city
awakened to the potential danger of uncontrolled
dengue and yellow fever mosquito breeding
and cooperated in an urgent community project.
By organizing the entire population of the city,
immediate results were obtained and
citizens continued the control program
to ensure permanent freedom from dengue and yellow fever.
Every community has a wealth of resource,
but its greatest resource is its people.
Capable leaders can develop the power and ability of the people
to assure a victorious mosquito-control program.
It's up to you!
[Music]